Bernie Pruss: Hello!
Bernie Pruss: Double check that I have sound.
Dhaval Thakkar: Hello! Good morning!
Bernie Pruss: Good morning.
Bernie Pruss: Good morning. I just okay. Good morning. I should have sound now
Bernie Pruss: were you able to hear me, or do I have to double. Check me. Try again.
Bernie Pruss: Testing the microphone.
Dhaval Thakkar: Can you hear me?
Bernie Pruss: Yes, I can hear you. Can you hear me?
Dhaval Thakkar: Hello! Can you hear me?
Bernie Pruss: I can hear you.
Bernie Pruss: Hmm!
Bernie Pruss: Let me put a chat out.
Nico Manzo: Hi! Bernie!
Bernie Pruss: Hey? Good morning, nico.
Dhaval Thakkar: Hello! Can you hear me?
Nico Manzo: Hi Deval.
Bernie Pruss: I think I'm hearing you, Deval. I'm not sure you're hearing us.
Dhaval Thakkar: Yeah, I I can hear you now.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, great!
Bhargavi: Hi, Brittany, how are you?
Bernie Pruss: Good. How are you? Could you help me? Make sure I can pronounce your name? Is it Bargaby?
Bhargavi: You have? Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Did I say it right? You you can correct me if I didn't do it right.
Bhargavi: No, no, no, that's right.
Bernie Pruss: Bargaby. Okay. Cool.
Bhargavi: I'm waiting for Ronnie to join.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Bernie Pruss: Ronnie.
Bhargavi: Rw.
Bhargavi: okay, she's just going to join in a minute.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, cool. And I think I see that and I'm not sure how to pronounce this name either
Bernie Pruss: Chiwali or Chiwali.
Bhargavi: Yeah, jolly Javid and dawal.
Bernie Pruss: Alright, great.
Bhargavi: They are from our development team.
Bernie Pruss: Awesome.
Bernie Pruss: and we have Nick on with us. Nick, is is helping me with kind of some of the
Bernie Pruss: business development stuff, and
Bernie Pruss: I guess that's the best way to say it. And he's Nick, do you want to introduce yourself from it, Nico? I'm sorry I didn't mean to say, Nick Nico Manzo or Nicholas Manzo.
Bernie Pruss: You can introduce yourself while we're waiting for Ronnie if you want. I don't remember. If you were on the last call that we had.
Nico Manzo: I don't believe so.
Bhargavi: I don't think he was on the last call.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. Cool.
Nico Manzo: Yeah, it's it's really nice to meet all of you. As Bernie said, my name's Nico. I'm part of the go to market side here for Cdc, just here to support Bernie and and make sure we ask all the right questions and understand kind of what you guys are looking for. But yeah, happy to happy to meet all of you. And thanks for joining the call today.
Bhargavi: Nice to meet you, too.
Bernie Pruss: And it must be like 9 Pm. For you guys in India. Right?
Bhargavi: Yeah, it's 8 30 in the night.
Bernie Pruss: 8, 30. Okay,
Bernie Pruss: does this is this, typically, what happens is you end up having to do meetings kind of in evenings? Or are there ways that people schedule meetings? So it's in the middle of your day when you work with the U.S.A.
Bhargavi: No, we usually work till your afternoon, I mean, up until 2 Pm. Est.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, I've been working with people in India for maybe 10 or 15, or maybe even 20 years now. And it's a i've seen a variety of things done, so that.
Bhargavi: Let me!
Bernie Pruss: Also a huge fan of Indian food for what it's worth, and I know there's a huge variety from, you know the country is so big
Bernie Pruss: and has so many different regions. But
Bernie Pruss: I'm getting hungry thinking about it.
Bhargavi: Have you been to India before.
Bernie Pruss: Not yet. I would love to come. There was a period where, while we're waiting for Ronnie. When you see her show up, we can change subjects. But since I've sat next to people from India for huge parts of my career, there was a period of time around 2010, and 2011, where I was asking for lists of movies that they recommended from Bollywood or from.
Bhargavi: I don't.
Bernie Pruss: Just movies in general from India, and one of the ones that I remember that stuck in my mind is was about Bhagat Singh
Bernie Pruss: is that? Is he relatively famous?
Bernie Pruss: Everybody.
Bhargavi: Yes.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Bhargavi: He was a freedom fighter.
Bernie Pruss: Exactly. And I I kinda like, I don't know. I like learning about the culture in the background, and
Bernie Pruss: I think it's good when people throw off their oppressors for you, me for saying that out loud, maybe.
Bhargavi: No problem.
Dhaval Thakkar: Great to hear about. I mean, yeah. Indian. Sorry. Yeah. Happy.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah, I would love to come visit someday. And I I trying to figure out how to make that happen. And it just
Bernie Pruss: I need some some client or customer to make it profitable for me to go to India. Then it would be great.
Bhargavi: Where do you live? In the Us.
Bernie Pruss: I am located near Denver. It's a suburb called Aurora. So it's not very. Yeah, it's not very far from Denver. And then I went to school in Boulder, Colorado, which is also not very far from Denver, but kind of the opposite direction where I am now.
Bernie Pruss: so I kind of like the Rockies.
Bernie Pruss: How about you guys? Where are you? What part of India are you guys in.
Bhargavi: I live in the South. I'm in Bangalore. I think double you.
Bhargavi: You stay in Ahmedabad right.
Dhaval Thakkar: Yeah, we basically in the western part of the country, which is Ahmedabad Jirat.
Bernie Pruss: And can you say that name again, Andabar? Do I hear you right.
Dhaval Thakkar: Yeah, okay, it is, yeah.
Bernie Pruss: And isn't Gujarat also? Am I saying that right in the western part of the country.
Dhaval Thakkar: Yeah. Yeah. So basically, we are in the state of Gulat. And the name of the city is Ahmedabad. It's very nearby place to where Gandhiji I mean Mahatma Gandhiji was born.
Bernie Pruss: yeah, there was it's been a long, long time now, but back around 2,003, 2,004, I dated a lady from Goodrat for a while.
Bernie Pruss: and so I would do a little bit of research where I did some research back then and but it was so long ago that my memory is a little faded.
Bhargavi: Oh, that's nice!
Bernie Pruss: Yeah. She was a lawyer who lived in the United States. I think she was one of the her 1st generation. Born in the United States her parents. Maybe maybe it's fair to say her parents were from Gujarat.
Ronny: Hey, everyone.
Bhargavi: Hey, Ronnie.
Ronny: Sorry I was late.
Bernie Pruss: No, it's okay. We're can. I just check on your guys schedule? I think we booked an hour. Does anybody have?
Bernie Pruss: Yeah, stop? Or do we need to, you know, plan on just.
Bernie Pruss: and we might not need all that time. I just.
Ronny: Okay, I really after this call, because I do have another call.
Bernie Pruss: You'll have to drop right at the end. Okay, good. That's fine. We just wanted to. I wanted to set that
Bernie Pruss: that I
Bernie Pruss: expectation for us right away. So do. We need to do any more introductions? We ha! I brought
Bernie Pruss: one of the guys that's helping me with our go to market strategy and
Bernie Pruss: Nico. He introduced himself before you came on Ronnie, but I just wanted to acknowledge he's on the call with us. He's really helping me make sure I ask the right questions, and that we don't forget things. And
Bernie Pruss: you know we we figure out the best way to help you guys.
Ronny: Do you know everything that's needed for this project with Bernie?
Ronny: Or do any of the developers have any questions? Because I know you guys had tried to do some export and we ran into some issues. So that's where Bernie's gonna come in now and be able to help us in getting all of the information that we were missing, and that we were looking forward to probably.
Bhargavi: Yeah, we we also have a Dev team on the call. So I think double. If you guys have any questions. As we discussed in the afternoon.
Bernie Pruss: Can.
Bhargavi: Go ahead!
Bernie Pruss: Before we go all the way down into the details. Do you mind if we kinda go back up and just set the context a little bit since it's we've had a few calls, and now I think Tom is gone, and Tom got the master services agreement signed in one of the next steps is to kind of figure out what we want to put in a statement of work or a scope.
Bernie Pruss: One of the things that we had talked about with Tom is to look at some of the headaches you guys are dealing with and maybe see. And I know, Chris. I don't think Chris Baker is invited here. But one of the ideas proposed by Tom is that we show
Bernie Pruss: or talk with Chris, and maybe with more with you guys about all the stuff that we had done for clean origin already, and you know they had invested over $600,000 in building a pretty, I thought it turned out to be a pretty cool bi system, and I just last night was editing an interview or cleaning up an interview that we did with the Cfo. The former Cfo, obviously of clean origin.
Bernie Pruss: and I really got aware again of how valuable the way that they were able to look at all the data in Snowflake, and how reliable that the process was.
Bernie Pruss: In very low maintenance. And so I just wanted to presence the idea again of
Bernie Pruss: one understanding what you guys are doing today and seeing if there's any
Bernie Pruss: appetite to think about the big picture, and or you know how we might be able to support Chris and the analytics people.
Bernie Pruss: And then who all is maybe using this data today. And whether you have, you know, if you have any headaches or pain points.
Bernie Pruss: I think I heard you say, Ronnie, on one of our calls, that there is some data that you're having to manually go, get, or work on.
Ronny: I think right now they're working on the magenta one stuff. I know that there's still some product details that are still missing, that they that, I think, is probably in Snowflake. That might be easier for them to pull and extract and enter and add it into our back end. Database I know square and kw.
Ronny: yeah, square and Kw. Are 2 places where I know I'm pretty. I remember the orders being in Looker, but I but we don't have any other detail, because they all used to be, because those are all completely separate systems, that for some reason they decided to get.
Bhargavi: And the other thing is within snowflake. We tried to pull the data, but we are really not sure which.
Bhargavi: Where the data, the entire data is hosted, or which Dv, we need to pull the data from.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, good, not good that you can't find it, but that helps us know what to look for. And then where will it go once you pull it out of Snowflake.
Ronny: Now, Bargaby, do you think? Or do you guys know where Chris normally would want his data saved for his power? Bi connections.
Bhargavi: I think it's good.
Thejesh Reddy: There is a onedrive there is a onedrive that he has so.
Bernie Pruss: Onedrive. Is that what I heard you say? Just onedrive.
Thejesh Reddy: Yeah. Yeah. So sorry. Go ahead, Tony.
Ronny: Sorry. I was just wondering if he has the onedrive for the power bi data.
Thejesh Reddy: Correct, correct.
Ronny: Oh, okay.
Ronny: So we.
Bernie Pruss: It sits on in files, on onedrive right. And then he would import that into power. Bi in some way.
Thejesh Reddy: That's correct.
Bernie Pruss: Do we know how many how many people consume the data that he or the the reporting that he produces
Bernie Pruss: like? Does he display that out to like leadership and marketing people or operations, people, or what is what? Who are the primary consumers of the power bi data.
Thejesh Reddy: So it's mostly the marketing. And our finance team. So basically, all the stakeholders right like again, each one has their own reports that they look out on a daily basis. But the overall big picture like the high level reports are always being looked by our CEO finance team and the marketing team
Thejesh Reddy: to kind of adjust the campaigns and all that.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, that makes sense. And then, yeah, they make decisions about the okay. Yeah. Chris.
Bhargavi: Going to join the call.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, awesome!
Bhargavi: Coming from a minute.
Bernie Pruss: That sounds great. How?
Bernie Pruss: And maybe I should wait for Chris for that question. I was just gonna say, like, how often does the data get refreshed, you know. Is he getting? And what's the lag, is it?
Bernie Pruss: Every night he gets fresh data, and that he can look at in the morning for the
Bernie Pruss: current day sales? Or is there some real time updates happening.
Thejesh Reddy: Definitely, not real time. So he does that daily once.
Bernie Pruss: Daily. Okay, that makes sense. That's typical.
Bernie Pruss: Daily loads. And then
Bernie Pruss: I think one of the things that you guys were worried about is having a common database of customers and purchases, so that you can treat people
Bernie Pruss: like returning customers instead of brand new customers right if they bought something on clean origin and website
Bernie Pruss: 5 years ago, or whatever. And now they're buying stuff through grown brilliance. You'd want to know about that history in one place does that? I think I heard you guys say that I just want to confirm. I understood that.
Bhargavi: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Bhargavi: We have. Chris.
Bhargavi: Hi, Chris.
Chris: Hi! Everybody!
Bernie Pruss: Hey, Chris?
Bernie Pruss: My name is Bernie. I don't know if we were on a prior call before I saw your your email address in my history, but I don't recall if you joined any of our calls before before Tom left.
Chris: Alrighty!
Ronny: One of them. Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, okay, great. So my name is Bernie and my, myself and a couple of my guys, we built the entire data warehouse
Bernie Pruss: system and managed it for up until you guys acquired clean origin and one of the things we've gotten a master services agreement signed at a minimum. We're gonna help you guys get the data out of the system that is now. And one of the things, Tom, one of Tom's ideas, was, maybe we would talk with you to just see if there's any appetite to look at what's possible.
Bernie Pruss: With potentially restarting the snowflake data warehouse and migrating your data there
Bernie Pruss: and using Looker again. And maybe that's a big that looks that sounds really big. But they spent over $600,000 building that they spent that 600,000 with us over 3 or 4 years.
Bernie Pruss: plus all the time it took them to think about
Bernie Pruss: and design. And you know
Bernie Pruss: test and all of that in the system.
Bernie Pruss: The other thought. Oh, the other thing that I did last night is, we have an interview with the former Cfo of clean origin. Jeb.
Ronny: Oh!
Bernie Pruss: Beckwith.
Ronny: Yes.
Bernie Pruss: Right, Ronnie. You know him, of course. Right.
Ronny: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: So he did an interview for us, and I just listened to it last night again, for the 1st time in like 6 or 9 months when he did it. And he really went into detail about how that data, and being able to look at the data in looker every day, really helped them make the right decisions and grow the business. And given that, you guys have acquired all the assets of clean origin.
Bernie Pruss: you, if you don't take a look at what's there in Snowflake? You may be throwing away a huge asset is just what I I would want you to think about
Bernie Pruss: any thoughts on that, Chris. As far as you know, pain points that you have today things that you know.
Bernie Pruss: If you were able to wave a magic wand.
Chris: Yeah, so we recently just had somebody join the team. That's kind of poking around with some data warehouse type things. We're nowhere near, you know, having anything like that built out. But he's doing some investigating. We do use power Bi, and we're pretty confident and comfortable with that. So I don't know that looker in terms of a visualization tool really makes sense, because then we just be having, you know, 2 separate ones.
Bernie Pruss: So you yeah, you would want to eventually migrate to one if you were to think about that. Yep.
Chris: Right? Yeah. So in terms of aggregating the data and storing it. You know that. I mean, that's definitely something that we and like you said migrating it out of Snowflake. Things like that. That's definitely something that we want to do. But like I said I, since we're already pretty established with power. Bi the preference would be to use that as as the tool, you know, from that standpoint. But obviously, you know.
Chris: However, we can aggregate the data. That's the piece that you know. Personally, I would be more focused on.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, the. So we like looker for a lot of reasons. And some of our clients choose power Bi, and we have right now our biggest client is A is A is also in retail. It's a hardware store chain up in the northeast, and they chose power Bi, and we've been building power Bi reports and actually managing all the infrastructure for them like for the last 2 years. And so we had to get really good at the power bi the underlying
Bernie Pruss: infrastructure being able to do incremental updates into the back end of power bi from snowflake and and then develop the dashboards. And so
Bernie Pruss: potentially, another idea might be that to reuse what you already have in Snowflake migrate the ingestion, the new data sources that that weren't
Bernie Pruss: being ingested by clean origin into Snowflake, and then point power bi at Snowflake. Before you came on the call, the guy said that you might be pointing it at files on a onedrive. Is that the way you do it today?
Chris: Yeah, we have a couple of different sources. But a lot of it is Csv files
Chris: stored on one drive. Yeah, yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah in, the thing is is, so we really like the the tool stack that we've been using, and there are new ones out there. But
Bernie Pruss: with 5 tran. As an example, we were able to. You know, you just we basically
Bernie Pruss: point 5 tran at the source database and it loads snowflake into a raw area for us, and then we use Dbt
Bernie Pruss: to aggregate the data together. So.
Thejesh Reddy: Like.
Bernie Pruss: I would say at least 80% of what you would need is already in there, and it would be a matter of sucking in some new sources and then flowing that data through.
Bernie Pruss: Are you familiar? I'm assuming, Chris, you're familiar with the idea of star schemas.
Bhargavi: Not particularly no.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Chris: I mean I've heard it, but I'm not particularly.
Bernie Pruss: Nope, it's okay. So most bi tools, will allow you to do things
Bernie Pruss: without a star schema. But the idea behind a star schema. And it's a theory or a way of modeling. It's also sometimes called dimensional modeling, where we build the tables to be very friendly for the bi tool, and that makes it a lot less work for the bi person in power, bi or other tools.
Bernie Pruss: Because we've already pre joined a whole bunch of the data. We have aggregated the data where it when it needs aggregating. And we have
Bernie Pruss: unioned all the like all the sales data together. So I'm most familiar with the data most recently from this hardware store we're working on. But as an example, they have
Bernie Pruss: something like 200 stores. Well, they're on their way to 200 stores. Maybe they're at 130 now. So they have about 130 stores.
Bernie Pruss: the sales data all gets pulled into Snowflake, and it comes in different tables for the sale, the return, and some of the fees that they charge that are not technically, as they don't consider them a sale, but they need to see them to calculate all the values.
Bernie Pruss: And one of the things that
Bernie Pruss: so it would be relatively easy, I guess, is where I'm trying to go to get all that data into Snowflake. Have it be aggregated in a way into a dimensional model that's gonna make your life
Bernie Pruss: much, much easier
Bernie Pruss: in power. Bi. And you wouldn't have to be thinking about copying files to onedrive. You would just connect Snowflake. I mean to snowflake with power bi and pull the data there.
Bernie Pruss: And you would. What we've done for
Bernie Pruss: Obichon, which is the hardware store is we?
Bernie Pruss: Have it automated so that
Bernie Pruss: we load the data every 4 at 4 am. Every morning. We aggregate the data and clean it up right after that, and then about 6 Am. We call a procedure that has an incremental load. Go into power bi, and then
Bernie Pruss: right after that it's available to the users in power bi with almost we. Occasionally we'll have something will go bump in the night or somebody.
Bernie Pruss: One of the things that we did one of the things that makes things go bump in the night. If if an upstream source system breaks something, then we have to go in and tweak it a bit to fix it. I remember one of the issues with clean origin is one of the suppliers.
Bernie Pruss: and, Ronnie, you might remember this, but my memory is that one of the suppliers started reusing the product. Id.
Bernie Pruss: And so.
Ronny: Oh, the poll!
Bernie Pruss: Oh, my God!
Ronny: That vendor skews, you know, diamond vendor skews get used all the all the time in the similar. So the thing is that we had overlapping because we had like 10 to 12 vendors. So some people use number scales, and if they use 5 numbers at some point with thousands of them. They're all gonna intersect.
Bernie Pruss: Exactly.
Ronny: The issues that we were running into with that.
Bernie Pruss: So we, when that happens, what we have to do is we have to create an artificial key called the surrogate key. That will map to the right combination of columns, so it might be the vendor and the skew, or it might be that the vendor in mi. 9, which is the Erp that the hardware store uses. They have a product, Id and a product variant id. And I'm assuming that you guys have that magento at least has that same concept where
Bernie Pruss: you, the particular ring and diamond might have one product. Id. But then the size of the diamond and the or I'm sorry, maybe the size of the diamond, but I was thinking the size of the ring, and maybe whether it's silver or gold, those are variants on a product. Id, do you guys?
Bernie Pruss: Ha! Is that still in your data like how it, how that product looks.
Ronny: And the parents. Goose.
Bernie Pruss: I'm sorry. Skews and parent skews.
Bernie Pruss: Yes, children and parents queue. So it hides the parents. Children school with all the metal types
Bernie Pruss: exactly. And and that's something that we had accounted for and built into the model. Anyway.
Bernie Pruss: I'm trying to think, Nick, do you have any suggestions on next questions or things that I've left out or didn't ask about.
Bernie Pruss: or Nico. I'm sorry to call you Nick.
Nico Manzo: You're good.
Nico Manzo: Honestly, at this point I think some of the questions that that we had discussed
Nico Manzo: that Tom had brought up was about some of the technical debt. I know that there is some software that you guys were using like Web Scaler, and some of the the Elt Etl tools that you guys are using.
Ronny: We had to switch our we had to switch our server entirely.
Nico Manzo: Okay.
Bernie Pruss: You switched your server. I'm sorry I didn't quite follow.
Ronny: Yeah. Right? Bargabyte, what we did.
Bhargavi: We did it in Jan January last week.
Bhargavi: we we should switch to nexus.
Bernie Pruss: Okay? And was that I did some research, maybe Nico, after we got off the phone. But I I dug into web web scale. And
Bernie Pruss: is that that's sort of like an operational thing more than a a bi thing, right? And a reporting thing.
Bernie Pruss: And is that what you switch to nexus for is all that
Bernie Pruss: operational sales systems and or is that something else.
Bhargavi: No mostly to, mostly for an efficient system, and also to reduce our costs.
Bernie Pruss: Got it. Yeah, that's important.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, I'm just looking at my notes and see
Bernie Pruss: Yep, I think we've covered a lot of it, you know. So
Bernie Pruss: your data warehouse guy, does he have any experience with dimensional modeling, as far as you know, or Snowflake
Bernie Pruss: Snowflake can be one of the most efficient and cost effective data warehouses that I've ever seen. I've been building data warehouses for 25 years plus a little. And when I found Snowflake. I realized I didn't want to waste my life on other products, because Snowflake is that much better than the rest?
Bernie Pruss: and I just I would hate to see you guys throw away that huge asset that you purchased when you purchase clean origin, at least without, you know, kicking the tires, or, you know, giving it a good
Bernie Pruss: overview.
Bernie Pruss: Chris or Ronnie. Do you have anything like any pain points that, having all the data in one place, would
Bernie Pruss: and kind of automatically. There every day would would reduce your pain and your labor and your
Bernie Pruss: maybe increase your increase the reliability, decrease the risk. That kind of thing.
Chris: Yeah, I mean, I'll I'll jump in. I gotta jump off in just a moment. So
Chris: I I definitely think, having everything together in one spot is, you know, a big help. You know. Obviously, we have clean origin, but we've got, you know, our other brands that are on different systems, things like that. So that's why I've been working with
Chris: this new guy just joined the team. To see if we can explore some of those options. I'm sure he's familiar with Snowflake. I don't know how much work he's actually, you know, done inside of it. But it's definitely something that we, you know.
Chris: assuming we can make the cost work on our side, whether it ends up being snowflake or or some other data warehouse solution. That we I would personally be interested in but right now, where we're coming from we don't have one. So anything beyond, you know, 0 is going to be a bigger investment right?
Chris: But to your point I I think, having it all together, would be great. I think I would just have to talk, you know, with this, with this guy that's joined the team, and and probably with the group on this call, internally.
Bernie Pruss: Are you able to share his name? Just so we can refer to him when we talk.
Chris: I'm not sure if he has an account set up, because I mean it was just last week that they joined the team, so his name is Onyk, though a NIK.
Chris: I guess.
Bernie Pruss: Okay? Well, that that way, at least in our notes, we can say, you know, Anik is the new data warehouse guy. And if you, you know, want us to talk to him or
Bernie Pruss: you know we can show him around if that would help, because
Bernie Pruss: we've now built 19 snowflake data warehouses in my career. I built a lot more than that. And so
Bernie Pruss: again, I just hate to see you throw away something you've already paid for, and a huge investment that those guys, you know made
Bernie Pruss: that you already own.
Chris: Right? Yeah, I understand. Well, I'll I gotta jump off because I've just double booked but that's kind of my 2 cents on it, and I'll see if I can talk with Onyx next chance. I get as well.
Bernie Pruss: That sounds great.
Chris: Alright! Thanks.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, I think we're down to 30 min. Right?
Bernie Pruss: do we want to talk about the specifics of Nico? If there's nothing else, I think we should talk about the specifics of the data that they've been trying to find. Does that make sense to you?
Bernie Pruss: And you're on mute? If you're talking to the microphone on mute. Okay, there you go.
Nico Manzo: Yeah, yeah, we can go into specifics for the this project.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, cool. So there, you guys weren't sure how where to look in the in Snowflake? Right? Because
Bernie Pruss: I know that we
Bernie Pruss: build with a very specific naming standard in in mind. And oh, that reminds me, Ronnie, and I don't see Ronnie there still. Maybe she scrolled off to the right. Okay, cool. We talked about possibly trying to get back the
Bernie Pruss: Jira slash confluence access, because there's so much documentation in there that really might have helped you guys or help us point you to the right in the right location if we didn't have to reinvent any of that stuff.
Bernie Pruss: Do you know if that's available or could be, we could try and make it available.
Ronny: If we can try and get access. But I know that I don't think that we were able. We. I know that we just we didn't get access to that. That was never Tran transferred. And then
Ronny: and yeah, and there's just been a lot going on.
Bernie Pruss: Do you want to ask Brian, or do you want me to reach out to Brian? I I just think there's you know.
Ronny: If you don't mind asking Brian. I know Brian is responsive. Likewise.
Bernie Pruss: Yep, I just know there's dozens of
Bernie Pruss: probably tens of thousands of dollars worth of documentation in there. If you had to pay somebody. Well.
Bernie Pruss: a lot if you had to pay somebody to go back and try to recreate it. And we have parts of that documentation like we document the data model. Or we could recreate a document of the data model pretty quickly. Because we have reverse engineering tools we use. But if there is.
Bernie Pruss: can we start to drill down like, what is the description of the data that you're trying to find? Could we say it that way? Maybe.
Ronny: What do you mean by descriptions of the data.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, subject area, is it? And you may have said it out loud already, and I just didn't let it land in my brain yet, or take a note. But is it the history of the sales that were in, you know from the various systems? Is it inventory data? Is it.
Ronny: No, it's it's it's all the sales history of the previous.
Bernie Pruss: History. Thank you.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, that I can point you to pretty quickly, I think. What about customer information that goes with sales? Right?
Bernie Pruss: So in dimensional modeling, right? We, the way that works is that that dimensions are
Bernie Pruss: the descriptive data about a particular transaction as an example sales history. So there's gonna be some of them that I remember off the top of my head without even looking at the documentation, is, there is what is the product that they bought, and all the details about the product and the categories of the product, and all of that are put into a particular in a dimension called product. There is
Bernie Pruss: The store, or the you know, in store might would also include the websites that you're selling from. So where was it sold from either a store or a website? There would be details about the customer, and we usually keep 2 sets of of information about a customer. There's the ship to, and the sold to because, you know, frequently right the boy. The man buys the
Bernie Pruss: the product and he ships it to his fiance, or and but not always right. So I saw in the analysis that more and more
Bernie Pruss: women will go in and buy for themselves. And so. But there's sold to ship to. We have a we always have a date dimension, because it's important in when you're doing this kind of reporting. You want to know? Not only what date did something happen? But what was the day of the week? What was the day of the month? What week of the month. What
Bernie Pruss: what month, what quarter those kind of things? So we pre-calculate all that and put it in a date dimension.
Bernie Pruss: So, although I said, all of that, because I just I'm trying to understand. If you have
Bernie Pruss: what?
Bernie Pruss: When you say sales history, do you have a list of attributes that you're looking for, or.
Ronny: I, at least I know they were so like. I know that it was specifically for kwi and Skew. I mean I. The only thing I do.
Bernie Pruss: Kwi.
Ronny: Yeah. Kwi and sq, square.
Bernie Pruss: And square. Those were the the and that payment type is another dimension.
Ronny: Retail stores, because those were completely offline, completely separate from our systems.
Bernie Pruss: The retail stores were.
Ronny: Yeah, when we 1st started with them, they were not we had started them with square that wasn't connected to anywhere internally in our system. Then we went to Kwi, and that was not connected internally with our systems, like magento and stuff.
Bernie Pruss: I what I can do is log in and look around a little bit,
Bernie Pruss: and try and it will take a little bit of exploring, probably, or I'll have to ask Andy about what he remembers. So sales history. Is there anything? And you'll need customer and the payment information, probably
Bernie Pruss: and the product that they bought.
Ronny: Yep, every product and and within that same order. You know, just the service plan and everything. We just need to make sure all the details are there. Whatever detail is in there, I know not. All the details are in there like the metal type, but that's more of a that was a square Kwi issue than it is with the data itself.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, is there another subject area that anything about inventory, anything about the product over time or.
Ronny: no, I don't think with the product over time or anything is going to be important, just because it's completely we're using their vendor and everything, so that that data is not as necessary.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Ronny: Unless is there a different place where the where, where? The cause I know, like it would pull the gross margin, based off like the date and the and the price and the and the item. Does that live on a separate table? Is that why you're asking.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah, we we separate.
Bernie Pruss: And and it's right. It's been a couple of years since I've been in there, so I won't have everything on the tip of my tongue. But I it's really easy either to look in
Bernie Pruss: look at the data and look at the Dbt, the way it's being transformed. And then also, maybe look. And I don't know if we have access anymore. But to look at Looker or the documentation. But typically we were calculating all the gross margin information according to how
Bernie Pruss: Jeb? And oh, there's another gentleman who's I'm going to go blank on. Do you remember who the guy we worked with the most. Addison. Thank you.
Bernie Pruss: So Jeb and Addison would specify how the calculation was supposed to happen, and then we would build it that way, and I'm sure there were, and I was involved early for very deeply at the beginning. And so I do remember that you have we had to find the right cost, and any other expenses that go with that sale.
Ronny: Case, then, yeah, we will. We will need that.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, Set another way. You need all this stuff for margin.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: And.
Ronny: That we could see margin costing, and everything, just so that we could see where, like where we were.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, is there?
Bernie Pruss: anything else that jumps out at you? Now, one of the things we offered to do in our last call with Tom is to, because we were helping and doing a few things. We weren't the main admin for your aws account, but we have a lot of experience, looking at aws, accounts, and what.
Ronny: Oh, actually costs money!
Bernie Pruss: There!
Ronny: Have you guys? I know I've asked you guys to look. That's exactly what I said is that I thought that maybe it was in the Aws account. Some of the data that's if it's already there. Bar give you. I believe that you guys had started looking.
Bhargavi: Yeah.
Ronny: You guys have started looking in there? Were you guys able to find it? Did you guys have difficulty in finding it? Should we have maybe.
Bhargavi: No, we need. Yeah, we need help there, too. Dawa, I think you you took a look at that right.
Dhaval Thakkar: To check other people.
Dhaval Thakkar: Exact location of that things.
Bernie Pruss: Are you?
Bernie Pruss: Do you? One of the things we'll need in order to really dig in is to make sure that our login still work for everything.
Ronny: Do you guys want to try first? st I know that I've had. I've asked for access, and I keep in having difficulty with access. So can you guys.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, even for you!
Ronny: Yeah. So if you guys can just do me a favor, just.
Bernie Pruss: Let me see if I what I have we. We use one password, and we keep all all of our stuff in there, and if I haven't archived
Bernie Pruss: hypothetically, I archived you to get it out of my field of view because I we hadn't worked with you guys in a little bit. And I think I just have to.
Bernie Pruss: yeah, I have to go and unarchive our passwords. Assuming that we that I archived them, I'm pretty sure that's what I did. So we can look and test that and see if we can get there. And I remember getting my password reset for Snowflake at 1 point when Snowflake turned off because they didn't have a credit card to Bill, and so they weren't getting paid. So they just turned it off. And that's, I think, when Tom.
Bernie Pruss: for one of the 1st times Tom really dug in with us to get that fixed, and so I know I have those pat logins there, and I just have to go on archive them, and
Bernie Pruss: if we have a few minutes at the end of the call. Maybe I'll try to do that, but I I don't wanna waste your time
Bernie Pruss: while I go do that.
Bernie Pruss: So aws the do you know who
Bernie Pruss: who is your primary? Aws admin right now.
Ronny: All the visibility right.
Dhaval Thakkar: Yeah, 3.
Bernie Pruss: No.
Dhaval Thakkar: We both are there. So we can create an IM user, and we can share the access if needed.
Bernie Pruss: That'd be great.
Bernie Pruss: okay, and it could be read only if you want and but we'd wanna if you want us to take a peek. We can also I what I remember from last time, and maybe you've already fixed this, but that you had a relatively high bill, and we were strategizing about what that could be caused by. And I'm not. My memory is not always perfect, so maybe you can correct me. But I think you guys had some Rds databases running relational database service.
Bernie Pruss: or there was something that.
Dhaval Thakkar: Aws! Aws! Bill was actually there was the web scale and aws! They both were costing around
Dhaval Thakkar: 9 to 10,000 a month, so in that we were paying almost only $1,000 to aws, and this is the amount to the web scale. So that was the whole from the
Dhaval Thakkar: whole recalculation. And I think we live in January. We moved away from the web scale so and move to the next role.
Dhaval Thakkar: So I think we should be okay. But this is, we want to get rid of some of the unused services like Ec. 2 Rds and all those things so that will take care from our end. But yeah, if you have any suggestion, do please do let us know.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah, it. It'll be hard to make a suggestion if I can't see what's costing you money. So that's where I when I request access. If I don't already have it, I would just ask. It can. Only it could be read only, but just to have read only for the financial and the the be able to inventory and see to see everything that's in there read. Only
Bernie Pruss: so that I can assess what you're paying for, and what I think I heard you just say is that either Web Scale might have been using some of the aws. And so when you got rid of web scale that reduced it, or you might have, cause I wasn't sure I heard you right, or you just
Bernie Pruss: off some of the expensive things in aws.
Dhaval Thakkar: No, no, as I said, the bifurcation was that we were paying $1,000 to aws, and 8 to $9,000 a month to the web scale. Now Web Scale was doing the managing of the all the services they were managing, the whole Aws infrastructure, and maybe they were getting they they are. They were charging for the same thing.
Dhaval Thakkar: But I think we got rid of the but still around January. And
Dhaval Thakkar: so right now what we are paying is around $1,000, but still we want to get rid of the some of the Ec. 2 instances.
Bernie Pruss: Yep.
Dhaval Thakkar: S. 3 bucket I'm pretty sure we are using it for our videos and other things. But Rds and Ec. 2, we would like to get rid of it. And magenta, one data also been transferred. So I think we should be able to get rid of some of the Ews and Rds instances
Dhaval Thakkar: and we should be able to do that. So that's something we can do. It.
Bernie Pruss: That makes sense. I, yeah, typically
Bernie Pruss: storage like what I think I remember. And what I think you just had is like the photos and maybe videos. I don't know if you do videos. But those files are stored on aws. And then
Ronny: Product photo.
Bernie Pruss: When the web server goes to pull them.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, sorry I have to turn off my.
Ronny: Not just guys. The the are all of our photos and videos are on aws. So that's 1 of the things we need to be aware of, and I think that might be one of the causes or reasons that might be that needs to be that the file is so big. Also the reason why I have. I have also been asking for ask it a access.
Ronny: It's also because we might have a lot of old images, old videos that were maybe Redone and stuff like that. And then we had duplicated the folder. But because the because one of the logins for the things that I had, so that I can connect it to S. 3. Browser only gives us access to certain other folders, and there's 1 folder. I'm pretty sure we had duplicate images of. That's gonna cause a lot of extra space that we're using in aws, too.
Bernie Pruss: Right. And one thing like one thing
Bernie Pruss: thing about aws, though, is storage, is generally relatively inexpensive, unless you do something horrible, horrible that makes like 50 or 100 copies of your data which could have happened. You know you never know and if you
Bernie Pruss: would like to have it around as what's called maybe disaster recovery, or you know, audit trail, or anything like that in Snowflake. I'm sorry I didn't mean to say Snowflake in Aws s. 3. They have a feature that you turn on, and it puts it in a deep freeze, and then it goes, you know, maybe from dollars to pennies. It's, you know, not very expensive at all. It's really really cheap, and they just move it off
Bernie Pruss: someplace, and if you need it, it might take a day or 2 to get it back right. It's not right there all the time, but they don't throw it away, so if there's any well, we'd probably want to look and see what's there first.st
Dhaval Thakkar: So, bonnie. Most of that billing, I mean. As you said, S. 3 bucket is charging very, very less. I'm not sure even at 10 or $15, even if that would be much.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. Good.
Dhaval Thakkar: 90% of that is going to the Rds auto scaling. Ec, 2 instances. Vpc, and all those services. Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: You'll need to have at least
Dhaval Thakkar: One or 2 Vpcs left, but they they shouldn't cost very much, but definitely. Ec. 2 instances IP addresses.
Bernie Pruss: Used. Rds, all of that is highly expensive and
Bernie Pruss: in a in one of the things that we can do when we shut off an Rds is, we can ask for a final snapshot, and then that's just a piece of another file, and that file will be stored very cheaply, so that in an emergency well, if you ever realize that you needed some of the data that was in the Rds, it's still there as a backup. So we just do a final snapshot when we turn it off, and then and then it just stops billing you when you kill it, and.
Dhaval Thakkar: Sorry.
Bernie Pruss: I've yeah. I've had to do this kind of cleanup a few times. And so
Bernie Pruss: yeah, I'll look for the passwords and see what I can find, and then
Bernie Pruss: anything we're down to like 12 min. Any what else should we think about that? Might any data, any cleanup, any
Bhargavi: No Bernie. My only question is, what would be our next steps.
Bernie Pruss: So what we'll do is we'll try and put this all together into some sort in a statement of work, and come up with an estimate of what we think. It's gonna take, you know, cost to do that for us to do that. And then are Ronnie, are you the one to review that with, or will it be somebody else.
Ronny: Yes, I guess.
Bhargavi: To be Ronnie and.
Ronny: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. Review the sow with Ronnie.
Ronny: Marketing.
Bhargavi: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Okay.
Bhargavi: Me and John. Yes.
Bernie Pruss: I can send it to you guys, and then you can share it as much as you need to to get your input on it and I don't think it's gonna be horrific.
Bernie Pruss: The we'd still love an opportunity to keep talking with Chris or your Aunt Nick, about
Bernie Pruss: I think, given all that we've done, and our that our our head has been in the jewelry business for 4 or 5 years. Now I think we could really produce a lot of results very quickly if you were to think about having a data warehouse.
Bernie Pruss: and I know that that's gonna save you and be able to.
Bernie Pruss: Chris will be able to produce a lot more results, a lot faster and have a lot less risk. If you had an you know, all those processes automated. But I I know that'll be a decision you guys will have to make. But
Bernie Pruss: we wanna we want an opportunity to at least think about it with you, or to find out to let you think about it, and then
Bernie Pruss: make a choice one way or the other.
Bhargavi: Oh, that works! We'll talk about it and.
Bernie Pruss: Sure.
Bernie Pruss: And then, Ronnie, we're there. It seems like I remember, and maybe you already said it, and I apologize if I'm making yourself, you repeat it, but I kinda have a vague memory of you telling me about some data that you're still manually processing
Bernie Pruss: or having to manually go get. Is that something you're able to would want to talk about today or.
Ronny: That was those specific orders. Because I only have Csv's of like some of the bare minimum information just from previous reports that I've done.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, it's the stuff that's in Snowflake, maybe. Or, okay. Good.
Ronny: I think it's either in Snowflake or aws, which is why I think that we should definitely check aws, because I know that that's where some of the backups went.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah, okay, good. Then we can explore for that. And I, I just if we can make your life easier without spending a lot more money we should make your life easier.
Bernie Pruss: is what I'm thinking.
Bernie Pruss: I don't know if you agree with having your life made easier.
Ronny: If only that could always happen, that'd be pretty.
Bernie Pruss: Well, Nico, unless you have any other questions or thoughts, or you guys have any other questions or thoughts. I think we've got what we need.
Bhargavi: Yeah, I don't have anything either.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. Now, I I do have a thought. Now it just occurred to me as I I thought for a minute more. Are you able to kind of share like. So I think we've done enough research that we kind of know who the founders were and who the CEO is, and one in. And at the beginning, when we 1st got introduced to Tom, we thought Tom was the new owner, the new CEO of the company, but now we realize that was he's was sort of a
Bernie Pruss: like the head of E-marketing, or something similar.
Ronny: He was in charge of e-commerce, but he was like the Vp. Of the company.
Bhargavi: Yeah.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, a Vp, and do we know where he went? Or or I just had the thought that I'd love to talk to him sometime, and I went to Linkedin, and it looks like he hasn't interacted much with Linkedin for like 7 or 8 years. And I I don't know if
Bernie Pruss: if it's appropriate, Ronnie, for you to share any contact information, if you have any
Bernie Pruss: or send him a note, if you could, you know that I'd love to catch up with him sometime.
Ronny: I'll give him a call just because I.
Bernie Pruss: Yeah.
Ronny: I'd rather just let let.
Bernie Pruss: Fine. I I don't want to violate any privacy or or confidentiality things, but I it would be great to talk.
Ronny: For anybody that I have their numbers. It's just like.
Bernie Pruss: Yes, that's I totally get it. I totally get it. And then the other thing that I'd be just curious about is kind of how the reporting structure works a little bit. So
Ronny: Does is the one that handles, that.
Bernie Pruss: He were.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, he might! He knows what the report you mean like he sitters.
Ronny: Entire, like the power bi everything. He's the one that made the recording.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, I was. Kinda I'm sorry. Maybe I said it wrong when I meant by reporting structure is, I mean, like, do you report up to the Cfo. Do you report up to the.
Ronny: See a oh, oh, I wouldn't deal.
Bernie Pruss: You report to the CEO.
Ronny: Yes.
Bernie Pruss: Oh, okay, cool. And then, do you guys have a Cfo, you know, like a person who does what jubbed, used to do.
Ronny: We do have accounting. They are in India. I'm not sure.
Bhargavi: Hmm, yeah, we do have a Cfo, but he is in India.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. Okay. So he maybe he's not doing the
Bernie Pruss: the day to day stuff sort of like Jeb used to do. He probably looks at all the books make sure everything works and things happen. Okay.
Ronny: Ella did.
Bernie Pruss: Pardon me.
Ronny: He does like what Bella did.
Bernie Pruss: What Bella did right. I remember Bella alright. It the other thing, then, is you report to the CEO, do you mind? Or or if you haven't already shared your title, what do or what do they call you, as far as your roles oper coo, are you the coo.
Ronny: Director of Operations.
Bernie Pruss: Okay?
Bernie Pruss: And then the marketing team do you guys have? If now that Tom is gone, or was Tom part of that
Bernie Pruss: the marketing piece.
Ronny: Side by side marketing team. We do have someone else who is in charge of the marketing team.
Bernie Pruss: Are they in the United States, or are they in India?
Ronny: Yes, they're in the United States. They're in New York.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, can you give me their name? Just so I can kinda have a sense of who's doing that kind of stuff.
Ronny: That one is just. It's Josh.
Bhargavi: Josh.
Bernie Pruss: Gosh, okay, okay.
Bernie Pruss: And those guys will be the ones that decide that. Look at reports and decide where to spend money. And on advertising and marketing, and.
Ronny: But they decide on the advertising and marketing for like the reporting stuff that's more with with Chris.
Bernie Pruss: Okay. But my thought was is, they would be the consumer of what Chris does to help them make their decisions
Bernie Pruss: so that they know how to do the spend.
Ronny: Some of it. Some of the reporting they do do themselves because they get it from Clavio and stuff like that. And they just get it directly from Google. Like the Google reporting and stuff like that for their different
Ronny: for you know how much money spent Roi's and everything. And but yeah, so it honestly, it really depends on what's needed.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, I just in the past. Sometimes we've pulled all the different areas together into one place. So they didn't have silos. And then they could use one tool to do their reporting. And and that's not always practical like, I know Google. What is it called Google?
Bernie Pruss: They just upgraded or not that long ago. But the thing that tracks everything that happens on your website.
Bernie Pruss: oh, they're just
Bernie Pruss: ga 4. Yep, Google analytics, 4. Sometimes people pull that into Snowflake. Sometimes they just query it in ga, because it's they don't need to have it integrated with anything else. So.
Ronny: Yeah, I mean, I'm not sure what the plans are for the integrations. With that that I would have to find out and look deeper with
Bernie Pruss: Do you guys have a CTO? Somebody like Brian was.
Bhargavi: No.
Bernie Pruss: Okay
Bernie Pruss: and like, have you seen, or any, or heard any discussions about maybe doing some data strategy like a big picture of, you know, long term planning for
Bernie Pruss: how you want to evolve your data systems and how the data should support the business strategy. That kind of thing.
Bernie Pruss: Sometimes they call those people a CIO or a Cdo chief data or chief information officers.
Bhargavi: Anything related to data. Chris is the one who is responsible. So.
Bernie Pruss: Perfect.
Bhargavi: Yeah, it's Chris.
Bernie Pruss: Okay, cool. I think that's that's all I could think of, and thank you for just giving me a little more context. So that we understand the business a little better, that we're trying to help you with.
Bernie Pruss: All right.
Bhargavi: Okay.
Bernie Pruss: I think I think we're good and we'll try and maybe get you something by Monday. Is that fast enough? Or and I'll but before then I'm gonna go look and see if we have access to the credentials and see what we can connect to.
Bhargavi: Yeah, monday is good. And meanwhile I'll also have a internal discussion with our team and see if we have any more questions, and I'll reach out to you.
Bernie Pruss: Alright! Alright, Bhagavi! Thank you and everybody else. Thank you, Ronnie. Thank you.
Nico Manzo: Thank you. Everyone. Bye.
Bernie Pruss: Guys have a great day and have a good weekend.
Ronny: Thank you, you too.